ja willkommen zu virtuellen
ersatzsitzung im Seminar Kant
Grundlegung zu metaphilfe 7 für den 6
juni 2023 heute wollen wir uns mit ein
paar Fragen befassen die an die letzten
Sitzungen anknüpfen und zwar welches
Gesetz bestimmt nach Kanton Willen
moralisch das ist ein ganz zentrale
Frage weil sich hier das Sittengesetz
schon zeigt und das ist eine der
zentralsten Themen dieser
grundlegend eine weitere Frage ist was
muss ich tun damit mein willemoralisch
ist oder moralisch wird und eine dritte
Frage betrifft das Gegenteil warum
handeln wir manchmal unmoralisch oder
wie können wir das unmoralischen manche
sagen auch das Böse erklären mit Blick
auf das Gesetz
das unseren Willen bestimmt sollte
ich bringe jetzt ein paar zentrale
Zitate und habe darin wichtige Begriffe
und Passagen
hätte hätte
zunächst steht die Frage nach kantin
Zentrum was für ein Gesetz kann unser
moralisches Handeln bestimmen
er sagt jetzt darin
unser Wille wird nicht dann moralisch
bestimmt wenn er durch Antriebe wie
Neigungen
bestimmt ist warum nicht weil Neigungen
immer nur empirisch sind und keine
objektive Moral zu begründen in der Lage
sind wenn wir unseren Willen durch
Neigungen Vorlieben individuell hat
bestimmen lassen dann handeln wir darin
immer individuell und eben nicht
allgemein und das fordert gerade die
Moral dass man allgemein gültig handelt
das können Neigungen nicht liefern diese
Allgemeingültigkeit die sind sehr
individuell unterschiedlich die eine
Person mag ihr das diese Neigung die
andere Person ihr das da auf dieser
Basis können wir keine Objektivität der
Moral begründen
deswegen sagt kann die Antriebe können
unseren Willen also nicht bestimmen dass
die funktioniert schon mal nicht
stattdessen kann es nur die bloße
Gesetzmäßigkeit überhaupt tun die dem
Willen zum Prinzip dienen kann was ist
jetzt damit genau zu verstehen mit
bloßer Gesetzmäßigkeit er meint damit
nicht den den Materialen Gehalt also
irgendwas was auf konkrete Zwecke
ausgerichtet ist kann Katja gesagt dass
selbst eine Absicht nach Kant nicht gut
sein kann weil eine Absicht immer auf
ein konkreten Gegenstand gerichtet ist
und der konkrete Gegenstand der betrifft
natürlich dann auch die Handlung und wir
haben gesehen Handlungen sind nach Kant
nicht das im Grunde genommen gut sondern
es ist der reine Wille den haben wir ja
schon eine andere Sitzung behandelt also
wie muss man sich jetzt die Bluse
gesetzt Mäßigkeit vorstellen ja kann
bringt jetzt ein weiteres Zitat und er
sagt folgendes wir können uns jetzt
dieses
allgemeine Gesetz genauer vorstellen
wenn wir uns
das Beispiel einer Lüge
überlegen er sagt nämlich hier unten so
werde ich bald Ihnen dass ich zwar die
Lüge
aber ein allgemeines Gesetz zu lügen gar
nicht wollen können man kann also
durchaus Lügen wollen aber nicht
vernünftigerweise muss man dazu sagen
ein Gesetz wonach jede Person Lügen
sollen dürfte das können wir nicht
vernünftigerweise wollen wir können es
überhaupt nicht wollen wenn wir den
Willen nach Kant richtig verstehen und
jetzt kommen die Begründung warum
widerspricht die Maxime also der
subjektive handlungsgrundsatz von dem
man immer wieder spricht warum
widerspricht die Maxime in manchen
Situationen Lügen zu wollen wie zum
Beispiel die Notlüge warum widerspricht
die diesen allgemeinen Gesetz er sagt so
werde ich bald Ihnen dass ich zwar die
Lüge wollen kann aber nicht als
allgemeines Gesetz der nach einem
solchen allgemeinen Gesetz der lügen
würde es eigentlich gar kein Versprechen
geben weil es vergeblich wäre meinen
Willen in Anziehung meiner künftigen
Handlung anderen vorzugeben die diesen
vorgeben doch nicht glauben Stichwort
für einmal blüht dem glaubt man nicht
oder wenn Sie es über alter Weise täten
mich doch mit gleicher Münze bezahlen
würden mithin meine Maxime nämlich
prinzipiell Lügen zu dürfen sobald sie
zum allgemeinen Gesetz gemacht wurde das
also jedes vernünftige Wesen diese
Maxime haben kann und jetzt kommt sich
selbst zerstören müssen eine solche
Maxime wäre nicht nur empirisch
unmöglich durchzuhalten weil dann
niemanden jemand mehr Vertrauen Glauben
schenken würde sondern kann sagt die
Maxime selbst würde sich zerstören also
die Maxime würde
offensichtlich als widerspruchsfrei
erkannt werden kann sagt es an einigen
Stellen er spricht auch davon dass eine
solche Lügen Maxime oder Grund
prinzipiell unmoralischen maximal sich
selbst aufreiben würde jetzt kann man
sich natürlich fragen inwiefern zerstört
diese Maxime sich selbst das ist ein
ganz interessantes Thema wo man
interessante Hausarbeiten auch dazu und
nicht nur Hausarbeiten Bücher schreiben
könnte
insofern widerspricht sich so eine
Maxime selbst inwiefern zerstört sie
sich ist es ein logischer Widerspruch so
wie wenn ich sage es regnet und es
regnet nicht
ist es ein performativer Widerspruch wie
der dass ich sage ich rede gerade nicht
da widerspricht die Form den Inhalt was
für eine Art von Widerspruch ist das
jemand kann jedenfalls sagen es ist eine
Art von willentlicher Widerspruch der
Wille widerspricht sich selbst ein
volitionaler Widerspruch den müsste man
natürlich mal genauer bestimmen ja ein
weiteres Zitat sagt jetzt kann hier ist
das Kriterium wie man jetzt feststellen
kann ob eine Maxime Widerspruchsfreiheit
verallgemeinerbar ist der sagt folgendes
das ist Diskriminierung fett gedruckt
kannst du auch wollen dass deine maximum
allgemeines Gesetz werde oder nicht der
Fall ist wie zum Beispiel bei der Lüge
da müssen wir diese Maxime verwerfen
weil die dann unmoralisch wäre
es sagt dass die Notwendigkeit meiner
Handlung aus reiner Achtung fürs
Praktische Gesetz dasjenige ist was die
Pflicht ausmacht also nur die Achtung
für das Sittengesetz darf ein Motiv
meines Willens sein nicht mein Streben
nach Glückseligkeit und so weiter und so
fort natürlich gilt die Achtung auch
nicht eine konkreten Person bei der wir
vielleicht Mitleid oder Respekt vor
einer großen Leistung haben das ist nach
kann nicht die Bedeutung von Achtung
sondern Achtung betrifft letztendlich
das sieht ein Gesetz selbst also die
Forderung die Maxime vernünftig zu
verallgemeinern wir sind diese Achtung
ist eine ziemlich abstrakte achtung die
nicht viel mit der alltäglichen Achtung
zu tun hat wenn wir etwas sagen alle
Achtung oder Respekt vor deiner Leistung
das hat nach kann nichts mit Moral zu
tun
Obst sagte Achtung gilt nicht konkreten
Person nicht Leistungen nicht Lebewesen
sondern der Pflicht selbst und das
müssen sich mal genauer vorstellen
kann dass diese Anleitung dass wir
unsere Maxime Allgemeinen können müssen
widerspruchsfrei vernünftigerweise wir
genau das geht zeigte noch an einer
späteren Stellung es sagt jedenfalls
dass diese
Orientierung wie man feststellen kann ob
die Maxime moralisch gut ist oder
moralisch schlecht dass man das mit
einem Kompass vergleichen kann also ein
navigationsinstrument im Bereich der
Moral gut oder böse welchen Weg muss ich
einschlagen zumindest wo geht's wohin wo
ist der gute Weg wo ist der schlechte
Weg einschlagen kann ich ihn dann immer
noch selbst aber ich muss zumindest mal
wissen wo die richtigen und die falschen
wie gesund also es geht darum zu
unterscheiden was gut was böse was
pflichtmäßig oder was pflichtig sei
und jetzt sagt ihr weiter unten dass das
praktische Vermögen des
Beurteilungsvermögen vor dem
theoretischen im gemeinen Verstande sehr
viel voraus habe es geht also darum dass
kann jetzt hier die theoretische
Vernunft mit der praktischen vergleicht
die theoretische Vernunft thematisiert
kann in seiner Kritik der Reihen
Vernunft die praktische Verlust in der
Grundlegung zu Mittag mit der Sitten
aber auch noch in der Kritik der
praktischen Vernunft und da besteht ein
gewisser Unterschied und zwar insofern
als die praktische Vernunft viel weniger
Voraussetzungen braucht um moralisch gut
zu haben um richtig zu funktionieren bei
der theoretischen ist es viel
komplizierter und auch nicht so
unmittelbar einsichtig wir sind da kann
der Wahrheit im praktischen mehr als im
theoretischen eine Asymmetrie zwischen
diesen zwei Formen von 55 theoretischen
und praktischer entspricht deswegen auch
davon dass die praktische vernünftige
Primat hat also den Vorrang vor der
theoretischen das praktische ist
wichtiger als die theoretische abstrakte
Erkenntnis ja es geht also darum dass
man etwas zum Richtmaß der Beurteilung
der Maximen braucht und es riechtmaß ist
eben das Sittengesetz was ich im
kategorischen Imperativ zahlt jetzt muss
man aber auch kritisch schauen nachdem
man überlegt hat wie kommen wir denn
jetzt zum Guten zu guten Maxime müssen
wir auch die Frage stellen warum oder
wie kommen wir zum Bösen handeln oder
zum unmoralischen Hafen
der Mensch fühlt in sich selbst ein
mächtiges Gegengewicht gegen alle Gebote
der Pflicht die ihm die Vernunft zu
hochachtungswürdig vorstellt an seinen
Bedürfnissen und Neigung
deren ganze Befriedigung er unter dem
Namen der Glückseligkeit zusammenfasst
wir sind so verfasst als endliche
Vernunftwesen dass wir nicht immer schon
dem Gebot dem allgemeinen sitzengesetz
folgen wollen warum ja mein Gegengewicht
und das ist deswegen uns vorhanden weil
wir ein endliches vernünftwesen sind wir
sind nicht reine Vernunftwesen wir haben
immer uns in uns noch Neigungen und wir
wollen individuelle Glückseligkeit auch
zum Handlungsziel machen und das ist
nach kann ein Gegenspieler der Vernunft
man kann durchaus sagen im Gegensatz zu
der Beziehung dass bei krank Neigung und
Vernunft miteinander um den Willen genau
um die Willensbestimmung konkurrieren
sagte daraus entspringt eine natürliche
Dialektik aus diesem Widerspruch in uns
das heißt ein Hang wieder jene strenge
Gesetze der Pflicht zu vernünftigen und
ihre Gültigkeit wenigstens ihre
Reinigkeit und strenge im Zweifel zu
ziehen und sie womöglich unseren
Wünschen und
Ellenbogen angemessen zu machen also wir
haben uns die Neigung weil wir eben auch
endliche Wesen sind die nach
Glückseligkeit Streben und nicht nur
nach Moral diese Pflicht Gebote die ja
kategorisch gelten wir sollen gar keinen
Fall Lügen ausnahmslos selbst wenn wir
eine Notlüge zum guten Zweck
beabsichtigen sagt kann ist das nicht
erlaubt ist das pflichtwidrig weil
dieses kategorische Gebot so unbedingt
fast schon unterm herzig würden manche
sagen kann natürlich nicht gebietet
haben wir uns die Tendenz dieses Gebot
abzumildern also nicht mehr so streng
aufzufassen uns gewisse Ausnahmen zu
erlauben
Ausnahmen zurechtfertigen dass man kann
das Vernünftigste also mit der Vernunft
gegen die moralische Vernunft anzugehen
und das sieht ein Gesetz etwas
abzuschwächen so dass es erträglich hat
das er kann das geht nicht gut weil
dadurch die Moral im Grunde verderbt
würde ja
wir haben noch ein Zitat er sagt nämlich
dass wir wegen der Quelle ihres Prinzips
und der richtigen Bestimmung desselben
im gegenhaltung mit den Maximen die sich
auf Bedürfnis und nahe und fußen
Erkundigungen deutlich Anweisungen
bekommen wir müssen also immer um
moralische Orientierung zu erhalten auf
das reine Sittengesetz achten auf die
Quelle des Prinzips auf die vernünftige
Verallgemeinerbarkeit und nicht auf
unsere Neigung
nachdem jetzt kann dem ersten Abschnitt
die
populäre sittliche weltweitheit
behandelt hatte geht er im zweiten
Abschnitt den wir jetzt auch noch kurz
beginnen auf die Metaphysik der Sitten
über wir hatten schon gesagt und
diskutiert was mit öffentlichen bedeutet
Metapher bedeutet sowie die Physik
eine Wissenschaft ist die sich mit
Gesetzen befasst
so befasst sich die Metapher Sitten
Gegensatz zur Physik als Metaphysik der
Natur nicht mit veränderlichen Dingen
nicht mit Dingen die dem Naturgesetz
unterliegen sondern mit Dingen oder
genauer gesagt mit Handlungen die dem
freiheitsgesetz unterliegen und dieses
freiheitsgesetz ist nicht zu verwechseln
mit dem Kausalgesetz obwohl es auch eine
ganz starke Form von Kausalität
beinhaltet und Bestimmung des Menschen
ja er sagt jetzt folgendes und das muss
man sich auch mal ganz gut ansehen in
der Tat ist das Schlechte Dings
unmöglich durch Erfahrung einen einzigen
Fall mit völliger Gewissheit auszumachen
da die Maxime einer sonst pflichtmäßigen
handlungs lediglich auf moralischen
Gründen auf der Vorstellung seiner bewut
haben wenn es zwar diesmal in der Fall
dass wir bei der schärfsten
Selbstprüfung gar nichts antreffen was
außerdem moralischen Kunde der Pflicht
mächtig genug hätte sein können und
diese oder jenerguten Handlung um zu
große aufopften zu bewegen es kann aber
durchaus gar nicht mit Sicherheit
geschlossen werden das wirklich gar kein
geheimer Antrieb der Selbstliebe unter
der bloßen Vorspiegelung jene Idee die
eigentlich bestimmte Ursachen das
gewesen sein
als wir wissen selbst eigentlich nie ob
wir jetzt wirklich ein moralisches
Prinzip unsere Willensbestimmung
zugrunde liegen haben es könnte sein
dass wir uns nur was vormachen dass das
vorgespiegelt ist das ist also nur so
scheint als ob das jetzt ein moralisches
Motiv ist dabei aber im Geheimen unsere
Selbstliebe also dem empirischen
Kontingenten Freund das ist natürlich
eine sehr kritische Ansicht kann seit
nicht nur dass das moralisch nicht in
den Handlung liegt der sagte sie dem
Willen und den Willen selbst können wir
nie mit absolute Gewissheit prüfen das
ist natürlich eine ziemliche ja starke
these die uns ziemlich unsicher
erscheinen lässt im moralisch
eine solche völlig isolierte metabilität
der Sitten die mit keiner Anthropologie
mit keiner Theologie mit keiner Physik
oder hyperphysik noch weniger mit
verborgenen Qualitäten die man Hypophyse
nennen könnte vermischt ist das ist
markant das Ziel das möchte in dieser
Schrift herausarbeiten also eine
Metapher eine Wissenschaft die nur auf
die Vernunft abzielt nicht auf
empirische Erfahrung rein Apriori vor
aller Erfahrung durch Begriff der
Vernunft soll
herausgearbeitet werden was wir tun soll
und nicht durch Bezug auf die Natur des
Menschen wie der Menschenmasse ist auch
nicht mit Bezug auf die Theologie auch
nicht Bezug auf das Naturgesetz sein nur
Bezug auf die vernünftig reine
praktische Vernunft das ist das Ziel
ja vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
wir setzen dann im Präsenz die Lektüre
fort mit dem zweiten Abschnitt von ganz
grundlegende